we have a voicemail number that's to 192
david p but this particular day I wanted
to read an email that came in this is
from a regular Trump this is a regular
email ur who is a huge trump supporter
happens to be a woman so I'm gonna be
saying her during during my discussion
and I genuinely wonder whether there is
some level of mental instability here
because the the emails are getting more
and more unhinged I'll put one up on the
screen for you this is an email from a
trump supporter and regular viewer molar
needs to look into the murder of Seth
rich it would expose where the Russian
like aim from the Russian lie is to
cover up Seth Rich's murder I am
convinced Muller knows that that's not
what he wants he has his sights set on
free he has set his sights on framing
Trump as far as I am concerned it is not
the Russian investigation call it what
it is time to call a spade a spade the
Muellers frame job this is not someone
connected to reality and you know
sometimes we wonder oh is hatred mail
real this is someone who's been emailing
the show for a very long time and it's
either the most incredibly well-crafted
uninterrupted trolling of the last two
years or this is someone who is
increasingly unstable and there's no way
to communicate this to her I don't know
why she keeps watching you know I know I
don't get that either but what is so
appealing about this show that you have
to watch for so long and comment if
we're just so diametrically opposed even
about our basic understanding as to what
the facts are here I liked how you read
it though I'm it sounded like your best
impression of the hey treat male voice
actor that we know is a no I wasn't
trying to do that but yeah we're adding
a little bit it's sometimes I have
trouble because when there's grammar and
spelling errors it becomes hard to parse
some of the sentences yeah and it sounds
like I'm having trouble reading which I
am but because of how it's written you
know right yeah on the bonus show today
I will talk to you about rush limbaugh
suggestions for preparing for hurricane
Irma a preview I don't advise you to
follow them we'll also talk about a sort
of confederate named thing in Boston not
actually from the Confederacy but
related to racism related to
discrimination
here in Boston that is now under
consideration for a name change and we
will also talk about free lunch to all
New York City Public Schools a great
bonus show today now the bonus show
available as a member at david
pakman.com slash membership and as a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show at the $5 per month level very
exciting check it out we will talk to
you on the bonus show